- Hello everybody.
You guys can all hear me okay?
Quick thumbs up 'cause
this is the first time
I'm actually doing this
on stage with a blank.
All right, awesome.
Great to have everybody on board.
I would like to do a quick introduction.
My name is Vinayak Shastri,
and I'm one of the product line managers
or of principal product
managers doing cloud detection
and response for CrowdStrike.
So today we'll primarily be be talking
about reimagining cloud security.
Just a quick check on the visual,
just wanna make sure that
everybody can see it.
- [Participant] I just waiting.
- Okay, there we go.
We are going to talk about
reimagining cloud detection
and response and with
agentic experience as well.
So we'll talk about a little bit of both.
The agenda at a high level
is to actually talk
about the latest trends
in the security space.
We'll talk a little bit
about the adversaries,
what they're actually up to,
challenges faced by the SOC team
in order to defend
against these adversaries,
gaps in today's cloud detection
and response solutions
that already exist and why
we're enhancing ours as well,
and how has CrowdStrike gone ahead
and re-architected the CDR space.
And we'll go through a quick demo
and talk a little bit about the
agentic experience around it
as well as a part of today's session.
So let's actually jump
into today's latest trends.
So everybody's heard
about Scattered Spider
or Crazy Panda at the end of
the day, come to our booth,
we'll introduce you to
some of these adversaries
at the end of the day.
So Scattered Spider in 2023 accounted
for one third of all the cloud threats
that our OverWatch team and MDR team
actually detected across.
That's actually a huge number.
But in 2024 that number
dropped down to 13%.
Does that mean they actually slowed down?
Not really.
What happened is there were
other adversaries contributing
and increasing that particular space.
So we're now seeing a over
rise of mature adversaries
coming into that landscape
and then talking about
how do we actually build
cloud threats in place.
So the challenging aspect around this
is they're not just
talking about the ecosystem
like the traditional way,
they're actually coming
in to build an entire
threat ecosystem within
the cloud infrastructure.
They're building,
they're using the building blocks of cloud
against us at the end of the day
and we have to figure out the
right way to defend ourselves.
Let's take an example of what
we actually looked around
for Genesis Panda.
We started looking at
their trends in 2024.
At a high level,
they started looking at
exfiltrating credentials,
either through a instance metadata service
or through other means,
and collecting credentials
from the cloud at the end.
And in April they transitioned
that into breaking
into customer's cloud accounts
and then accessing their
cloud infrastructure and VMs.
They did not stop over there.
What they did was they laterally
moved across the systems,
built their own infrastructure
within the customer's ecosystem,
and connected them to the C2 domains,
or the control domains
at the end of the day.
How did this change and enhance?
By March, 2025, we saw a
complete change in persistence,
which means we've started
seeing threat actors
establish SSH keys within
the infrastructure.
Persistence log into that infrastructure
without having to touch
an endpoint at all.
And that was the crazier part.
They're using your own
infrastructure against attacks
that they want to actually perform.
So how do we defend against
this more specifically?
Well, let's actually talk about,
now that we've seen the ecosystem play in,
how does AI enhance this?
Everybody has seen the
evolution of gen AI,
large language model
help with various things
at the end of the day,
is being used for good and bad at the end.
And adversaries are also leveraging AI,
improving their speed, efficiency,
starting from reconnaissance,
enhanced reconnaissance,
something that used to take hours or days
now actually take minutes or even seconds
for that matter at the end.
Vulnerability exploitation.
Think about somebody in the past
that had to do vulnerability exploit
in order to reverse
engineer a vulnerability
at the end of the day, create a script.
Today I can just feed it into an LLM
and then have a script ready for me.
Does that actually mean the
script's actually perfect?
No.
But what it's actually doing
is actually closing the gap
between an exposure or
a vulnerability exposed
and an attack that could
actually potentially happen.
What does this mean for us as defenders?
It means the time to closing
the gap is reduced, right?
Malware and advancements.
We've seen this day in and day out
where they've been able to build tools
that actually helps them translate
across various
infrastructure within seconds
at the end of the day.
Technical support.
Everybody uses gen AI and LLM
in order to enhance their skills.
What has happened is the
entry has gotten much lower
at the end of the day.
There is a lower barrier to
entry into breaching the cloud.
All of this has changed
the game both for attackers
or the adversaries and
for us as defenders.
So let's take a look at what has changed
in the landscape of defenders.
What do you have to deal
with, very specifically?
According to our CrowdStrike threat report
and 2025 threat report,
we've actually observed
that a median break-in time
has actually been lowered to 48 minutes.
I'll let that sink in, even for what.
The fastest break in time that we've seen
is somewhere around 51 seconds.
Take some time to realign
that with security operations expectations
in terms of SLAs.
How quickly can you respond
to a particular detection,
let alone detect it, right?
And how quickly can you
actually respond in real time
in order to remediate it?
So 51 second was one of the
fastest observed breach time.
The cloud makes it even more challenging.
Why?
Number one, no inline sensors.
If it was just sensors in
the virtual machine compute
at the end of the day,
you could potentially
get some real time data.
But in the cloud we are actually relying
on events from CloudTrail.
How do you get inline
sensors from the cloud?
Two, complex and siloed investigation.
Everybody knows how many products
are consuming your CloudTrail,
flow logs at the end of the day,
identity that is being sourced
from another product, right?
Where does this all come together?
Worse, it's actually piecemeal,
which means you have these
puzzles coming from each places
and you have to put them together.
Instead of having to respond to an attack,
you're now trying to
figure out what an attack
actually looks like.
And then finally,
once you've actually
put the pieces together,
responding to it.
Unlike traditional
workload protection sensors
where you can actually go
ahead and kill a process,
quarantine a particular host or a file
within that particular workload,
how do you address
responding to cloud APIs?
How do you quarantine an identity role?
How do you go ahead and
quarantine an S3 bucket, right?
All of these are challenges
that are actually faced
by defenders on a day-to-day basis.
How do we change it?
How are we re-imagining
cloud detection and response?
If we go out to the first problem,
what if we could see the
control plane activity
in real time?
There are ways to actually
pull in CloudTrail logs
in real time as well.
Complex and siloed investigation.
This is the biggest challenge.
People put an AI around everything,
but AI needs to have context of everything
before it actually gives
you a proper response.
Otherwise it'll only give you a response
of how much it actually
understands and knows.
So this includes
understanding the data plane,
the control plane, flow logs,
audit logs at the end of
the day, Kubernetes logs,
understanding how they all come together
with proper timestamp.
Imagining having a centralized location
where you could actually correlate that?
And then finally having
the same automated response
that enables you to accelerate
response time in the cloud
where you could actually
go ahead and quarantine
a particular bucket or go ahead and revoke
a rogue access token in place.
So what we've actually done is reimagined
CrowdStrike's Falcon Cloud security.
We always think from an
adversary point of view.
What does it mean to hunt for attacks
from an adversary point?
What is Scattered Spider
actually thinking about in place?
What is Crazy Panda
actually thinking through?
Detect early activity
through indicators of attack
in the cloud.
Reconnaissance attacks.
These can actually come
through early in the process
before a breach actually happens.
Understand the timeline.
And then stop the breaches
right in the workload
using some of the
workload sensor protection
or the ability to use fusion, right?
Finally, enable your SOC
team to help investigate
that with timeline.
Understand the sequence of events
of what exactly happened in scale,
and then at scale built in automation.
We'll talk about each
one of these in place,
but overall we think about two things:
one is adversary focused;
two, prevention first in
order for you to go ahead
and prevent a particular attack
or block a particular attack,
we don't want you to wait.
Prevent first and then figure out
where that breach actually went through.
How do you remediate it
during a long term process?
To meet the needs and speed
of modern adversaries,
we've gone ahead and
re-envisioned what it means
to actually have cloud
detection and response.
Number one, real time
visibility and detection,
both from an ingestion standpoint
and from a detection standpoint.
We'll talk about this in
terms of what is a new engine
that we are actually using.
Two, correlation and contextualization.
It is very important to
correlate a particular threat
by bringing down all the
risk associated with it
starting from assets,
understanding what is
the layout of the asset.
Is it a container? What is it running?
What's the namespace around it?
Understanding the risk associated
with those assets as well.
Bringing in all sorts
of logs from CloudTrail
to flow logs and
aggregating them together.
Then using machine learning,
then using agentic AI to actually
make sense of those logs.
And then finally, the
last piece of the puzzle,
starting from detection and response,
the response part of it,
which means now I have
to be able to go ahead
and automatedly respond
to some of these attacks
as they actually come in.
You could potentially build
some with manual intervention
as required,
but execute an API response
as a part of the strategy
where you're putting down
the flames right there
and then trying to figure out
what is the wrong term
remediation strategy.
So to do that,
we are introducing a new
engine within cloud detection
and response.
Starting from ingestion,
as I mentioned earlier,
the logs are actually streamed
and the detection is applied
while it's actually in stream.
Two, this reduces the detection
from minutes to seconds
at the end of the day.
This is very important in
order to go ahead and respond
back to a threat that's
completing in 51 seconds.
And this is tested and
used by OverWatch team
and MDR team over the last decade.
And they almost ingest 5
trillion events per day
and ran this at scale.
So we have this built in
within the product today
and we're actually launching
the real time detection
as a part of the new launch.
Two is unified detection part.
We can't have silos anymore.
Identity in one place,
cloud detections in another place
where sensor-based
detections in another place.
Most of you use different vendors
in order to collectively put
those detections together.
The challenge then becomes
how are you gonna aggregate
these detections together?
Make sense of it, right?
A SOC cannot view a detection
from a single point of view.
They have to look at it
from a holistic angle.
Same thing with agentic
or if you're using AI,
you can't provide it a siloed approach.
You have to provide it
the complete feedback.
So how do you enrich that investigation
with unified detection?
So correlation becomes more important.
Finally, accelerating that response.
Now that you have actually
provided more context around it,
it's then we apply Charlotte AI to go in
and provide summarized
details with context.
Runtime actually provides
all kinds of context,
so Charlotte will actually go
ahead and triage a detection
as soon as it actually pops up
with complete summarization in
terms of what happened, why,
and what is the response to be taken.
Expert-led decisions at the end of the day
where you actually have
agentic AI coming in.
And I'll talk a little bit later
during the session in terms
of the different agentic
experience built into the product.
In essence, what we are
doing is bringing in agentic
experience to go ahead and
correlate, tell me what happened.
You run manually at the end of the day,
experience it from a SOC perspective,
reduce the SOC time from maybe 60 minutes
to 60 seconds at the end.
And finally leveraging Falcon Fusion SOAR
in order to respond to
some of these attacks
in real time, right?
We're not gonna be able to sit down
and then detect a particular detection,
triage it over time, and then
respond back to it manually.
So how do I actually build
that into my change in order
to actually do real time detection
and response and then
triage it to figure out
what is the long term strategy for it?
So that is where we actually go
and integrate it with Falcon Fusion
with out of the box response flow
that has been built into the product.
There is always concerns about automation
at the end of the day where
automation on end-to-end
could actually disrupt my business.
Yes, you can actually
have human in the loop
at the end of the day to
validate some of these systems
as they go through.
This also accelerates the whole system
as things actually progress.
So finally, I'd like to
take you through a demo.
So let's actually get into a quick demo.
Wow!
- [Narrator] This demo
reflects common trade craft
used by cloud conscious
adversaries like Scattered Spider.
After compromising a
developer's AWS credentials
through social engineering,
a threat actor uses the
cloud shell command line
to create a new SSH key pair.
Establish an IAM role with
administrative privileges
and launch an EC2 instance
with the privilege role attached,
achieving persistent administrative access
in under one minute.
In the Falcon console,
we can see detections from
the suspicious activities.
However, what's more interesting
is we can see the graph view of the attack
unfolding in real time,
providing complete visibility
into the threat actors movements.
Our detection engine
enriches cloud telemetry data
with asset inventory context
to accurately identify
malicious behavior patterns.
Falcon had never seen this
developer using clouds shell
for deployments before,
immediately flagging this as anomalous.
Additionally, the specific sequence
of the threat actor's actions,
creating an administrative IAM profile,
attaching it to launch
an unmanaged EC2 instance
with a new SSH key pair,
clearly indicated highly unusual activity
that deviated from
normal baseline behavior.
Based on this activity,
Falcon platform immediately
invoked automated fusion
workflows to contain the threat.
A workflow was invoked
to deny further access
for the developer's compromise credential,
effectively cutting off
the attacker's entry point.
To take a step further and
prevent additional damage,
another Fusion workflow was invoked
to stop the EC2 instance
from being launched
while preserving the instance disc
for forensic investigation.
The Falcon console provides
a detailed timeline view
of the attack.
The threat actor attempted to log in again
via the cloud console,
but their access was denied
with an error message.
This is how Falcon cloud
security is empowering you
to stop the adversary at the speed
that modern attacks demand.
- Okay, let's actually switch
back to the PowerPoint mode
and then talk a little bit about the demo.
As you actually saw, all
the way from detection,
enhancement in terms of
triage using both Charlotte AI
and agentic AI,
we've been able to
respond back to a threat
and then triage it much easily
at the end of the day, right?
A lot of these response are optional,
but we always let
customers make a decision.
Do you want manual intervention?
How comfortable are you
with revoking rogue tokens
at the end of the day, right?
So it's very important to go
from detection to response
in seconds without having to wait.
And you have Charlotte
AI that comes in later
to actually help you with triaging
the whole content altogether.
Okay, now...
Okay.
Trying to go back to the PowerPoint.
So now let's talk about
ag agentic experience
in the whole system, right?
Now that we've seen the whole experience
going from detection all the
way to response in seconds
at the end of the day,
agentic comes in multiple ways
and CrowdStrike has actually
launched agentic AI bots.
Number one, it's actually
helping you increase
the productivity of your SOC team.
Let it be doing manual triage
and then responding or doing
a triage after the response,
there is a triage time that
actually comes into play.
When we bring all the data together,
an expert AI agent saves weeks of time
from a SOC perspective.
And number two,
this means to say your
mean time to respond
if you're trying to do things
manually is actually reduced.
Our whole goal at the end of the day
is to help you reduce your
MTTR for every detection
and help you automate the
triage as much as possible.
And finally, the most important piece
that actually comes in is
combating skill shortage.
You have SOC admins
that are actually looking
at SOC across the board,
they're looking at platforms,
identity, on-prem, cloud,
SaaS, and they can't be
an expert on every level.
While we have actually
observed some customers
actually carve out cloud
security operations
to actually go look at cloud specific,
contextualizing it with the cloud data,
it's even more important at this point
because you have a shortage of SOC admins
that actually understand
the cloud world really well.
And then finally,
all of these pre-trained
agents come out of the box
from a security data perspective.
So where you can actually go ahead
and have a triage specific agent
that will help you
triage across the board.
You're not only looking
at a silo detection,
but you're looking at a detection
from a complete context:
threat hunting agent, vulnerability agent,
response agent at the end of the day,
how do you want to bring in?
The way that these
agents have been trained
and scale has been through our MDR
and incident response team.
So OverWatch team and Falcon Complete team
at the end of the day does this in and out
and years of research has actually gone in
and we've built our own intel books
and advisory best practices
at the end of the day.
So this helps.
These agents are just getting started.
We plan on building more and more agents
as they actually come in.
They may have overlapping capabilities,
but their whole goal is to
help you reduce your meantime
to respond to a particular threat
regardless of where it actually happens.
And finally, I'd like to bring you back
to the whole agentic AI security platform
that we are actually building together.
We start off with a single
unified sensor in place
that actually sits on Linux,
windows, Mac, Kubernetes,
and containers at the end of the day.
Helps you associate and layout
with an enterprise level
graph that tells you
what is the risk associated,
what is the asset details
associated with it.
And you then have
detection across the board
that actually overlays endpoint detection,
cloud detections, SaaS
detection, identity detection.
You saw cloud threat detection
and response is just a
single component of it.
All of this kind of merges
into become either MDR
and CDR together
where our managed detection
team is looking at it
or cloud detection team
will be looking at it.
And over encompassing the
entire thing is our agentic AI
and AI agents which is now
getting the complete context
without having to lose context on identity
versus cloud versus SaaS.
The breach might have happened
at a SaaS application level
where the identity breach
has actually happened,
across the board now it
has spawned into cloud,
cloud to workloads,
workloads now they're actually breached,
laterally moved into the cloud.
When you're looking at silos,
you're only figuring out what
those silos actually mean.
But when you're looking at it
from a holistic point of view,
you go down to remediation instantly.
Second thing you figure out is,
how do I make sure this
doesn't happen again?
What is the remediation part of it?
And it's very important for us
to have a holistic view
in order to get to that level of details.
So that's the session.
Thank you for your time today,
and would love to spend
some more time in the demo.
Please stop by our booth.
And if you'd like to take
a look at our adversaries
and then take a look
at some of the details
around adversaries,
we're more than happy to
talk to you around in there.
Thank you very much.